Maria malevska and her cameramen are
covering the war from her teeth in the
midst of near daily Russian attacks
since the Invasion the government has
taken control of her Channel and most
others now they broadcast 24 hours a day
what's known as a United news Marathon
showing only the official Narrative of
the war
the most difficult thing for me is that
there can be no balance in journalism
standards in Ukraine right now because
we're here in hakeef and see Rockets
flying over us from their God who should
I ask for balance for a different
opinion
for military reasons information on
casualties after Russian attacks such as
this one on a student dormitory is often
unavailable Ukraine also gives reporters
only limited Frontline access
we have to understand that it's not a
honest game
it's a game without rules
from one side at least so and uh
we have to understand that uh
uh too many opportunities for Russian
propaganda
to make honest journalists a kind of
weapon against Ukraine
and manipulation with journalist
standards
it's one of the most important weapons
of war media freedom is often one of its
first victims
a yeva the chief editor of the Pravda
online newspaper says the marathon
broadcast should stop because it
violates media Freedom she says that
especially during wartime journalists
should be able to hold their government
accountable it's even more important
during the war because Ukraine plays a
very huge high price to be independent
to be Democratic and to be European
State and that's why there is no time
just to
stop thinking about reform stop thinking
about transparency stop thinking about
kind of misconducts of hyper officials
some government officials lost their
jobs after puff that expose all changes
are so difficult in this country
that's why it's very difficult just to
be optimistic sometimes because as a
journalist I can't
okay
I can't I can't give up
the air raid siren serving as a reminder
that journalists work is not only
hampered by government restrictions but
that their lives are at risk every day
stop fast and Al Jazeera give